banning russian oil and gas u.s
president joe biden said the moves aimed
at hitting the main artery of russia's
economy but what are the consequences
for the rest of the world and will it
stop vladimir putin's war on ukraine
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm adrian
finnegan u.s president joe biden has
imposed a ban on russian oil and gas and
the uk announced that it will phase out
imports of russian oil by the end of the
year before those measures were
announced russia warned of catastrophic
consequences for the global economy our
white house correspondent kimberly
halcott reports
it's a major escalation of u.s economic
sanctions against russia for its
invasion of ukraine on tuesday u.s
president joe biden went after president
vladimir putin's most lucrative industry
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy that means russian
oil will no longer be acceptable at u.s
ports and the american people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
the decision by president biden to ban
russian energy imports into the united
states follows pressure by the u.s
congress and pleased by ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky
biden acknowledged the latest sanctions
could cause a spike in u.s gas prices
consumers are already paying on average
more than four dollars a gallon up from
2.77
just a year ago due to high inflation as
the economy recovers from the coveted
pandemic
since putin began his military buildup
on ukrainian borders just since then
the price of the gas at the pump in
america went up 75 cents
and with this action it's going to go up
further
the white house is directing the release
of some of the u.s strategic petroleum
reserves to contain prices and
compensate for lost supply but the white
house maintains high gas prices might
also encourage u.s consumers to switch
to green energy and electric vehicles
but this analyst says the united states
is nowhere near ready the biggest user
of oil in any country is transportation
and transportation depends on having
things like electric vehicles and hybrid
vehicles those vehicles represent a
relatively small part of the fleet the
fleet turns over slowly so between time
we're talking about years
that's why these latest u.s economic
sanctions against russia may be symbolic
designed to hurt putin financially but
mostly politically
president biden is sending his vice
president kamala harris to poland and
romania this week to reinforce support
for ukraine but also to reassure nervous
allies fearful that russia could turn
its aggression on them next
kimberly hell can al jazeera the white
house
clear that gas prices affect our economy
i drive a lot i put many kilometers in
and i do feel it
absurd 15 days ago nobody could think
about it the problem is not the price it
will be tomorrow but how much it will
cost in 15 days i think bad times are
coming but we will have to deal with it
my purchasing power will decrease i will
have to choose between using the car or
doing other things
well we'll bring in our guests in just a
moment but first let's take a look a
closer look at russia's role in the
energy industry russia is a commodities
powerhouse it produces more than 10
percent of the world's oil and natural
gas and europe relies on it for a third
of its gas but sanctioning this sector
would send energy prices surging even
higher affecting an already fragile
world economy with russia being a major
global supplier it could also mean more
profit for russia not less
the u.s and its allies have agreed to
release 60 million barrels of oil
reserves to help offset any shortages
although the world consumes 100 million
barrels every day and analysts say that
no oil producing countries can replace
russia's oil exports to europe
let's bring in our guests then joining
us from washington dc is ben cahill a
senior fellow energy security and
climate change program at the center for
strategic and international studies from
burn cornelia mayer is an economist and
ceo of the consulting firm mayor
resources and from moscow leonard savin
chief editor of
are you at a political analyst a warm
welcome to you all ben let's start from
you
about how the eu get got itself into
this mess it relies upon russia for what
something like 27 percent of its oil and
imports around 15 percent of its total
consumption why is then europe so
dependent upon russian oil and
could any other supplier replace it
quickly
well thanks it's good to be with you
today um this is partly just a matter of
geography its proximity um the continent
is connected to russia by pipeline
systems
we have the jerusha pipeline which is
the main export pipeline from russia
into europe reaches lots of countries
through both the northern and southern
army and we have a lot of seabourn
exports that go to europe as well
so europe is the critical export market
for natural gas and for oil for russia
if you look at crude oil specifically
about 60 of russia's exports go to
europe about 35
to asia primarily china and the rest of
different places around the world
and so in terms of whether or not europe
can diversify and find an alternative to
russia the answer is no and the
immediate term is just not possible
um
the european commission came out with an
emergency plan yesterday basically to
try to do everything possible by next
winter to reduce its dependence on
russia for natural gas supplies
including building gas storage
trying to find alternative supplies from
us lng and other
supply sources
and managing the demand side too but
it's really difficult
it's important that europe has a sense
of urgency it's moving fast but it's not
something you can do within a year all
right cornelia i see you nodding in
agreement in terms of oil what about
countries like venezuela with its vast
reserves the u.s has opened up
diplomatic channels again with caracas
recently or even iran negotiations there
appearing to head towards a comp a
conclusion over the the nuclear deal if
sanctions against iran were lifted could
those two countries for instance at
least help to plug the gap
they can't pluck the gap because what if
you take out russia exports eight
million barrels a day that's 8
of global daily consumption
um and so they can't and you have seen
that opec plus you know the opec
countries and their 10 allies which by
the way are led by russia really can't
can't pump it fast enough and the spare
capacity is really spare it's really
sparse it's it's it's not there except
for saudi um uae and the little bit of
iraq so that's difficult now let us look
at adam venezuela yes obviously they can
go and talk to venezuela and the
venezuelans may actually be receptive to
talking to them because so far when they
were under sanctions from the u.s the
russians have been their only friends
but they're obviously worried that if
money dries up in russia what will
happen to them they need those direct
payments but better the national oil
company is woefully underinvested and
it's just you know it's no longer it
used to be one of the shining lights in
the oil industry it's now
very much near the bottom as a player so
he can't just ramp it up like that and
iran similarly iran could bring in 1.2
1.3 million barrels a day if the jcpoa
the nuclear deal went through they have
a lot in storage which they can release
immediately the 1.2 1.3 million barrels
a day of exports and they will take more
time but mind you the jcpoa is
negotiated by the p5 the permanent five
of the un security council and germany
p5 plus one guess what russia is a
member of the p5
so why can't opec step in and pump more
oil
well opec can step in to a certain
degree but opec doesn't have as i said
before it doesn't have to spare capacity
let me give you an example they have
done they have cut out 9.7 million
barrels a day on
after that grim day in april 2020 when
wti went negative for a day
and they've released gradually 400
thousand barrels a day month on month on
months but if i look at at the numbers
for january they were supposed to pump
the the the thirteen nations four
hundred thirty four hundred incremental
barrels they only were able to pump 160
000 barrels now again saudi can do more
russia was constrained and you look at
libya and nigeria they just they just
can't keep up ben the de facto leaders
of saudi arabia and the uae have
declined to arrange calls with president
biden in recent weeks that's according
to the wall street journal citing u.s
and middle east officials what's good
what's going on there
i think that riyadh and abu dhabi are in
no mood to do favors for washington and
they're making political demands they're
trying to use their leverage at the
moment
um if we look back to last week opec
plus had a meeting
you know right after the war broke out
and that meeting lasted for all of 13
minutes and they basically decided to
continue the deal that cornelia just
mentioned which is to
add 400 000 barrels a day
into the market
and continue what they've been doing
since last april i think there were
several reasons for this
first you know it it's going to take a
while still from today to absorb the
magnitude of this supply shock from
russia we still have a lot of questions
about the physical disruption and how
big it is exactly
but i also think that the issues around
spare capacity are real
you know the this price surge has been
so big there's so much fear and panic in
the oil market now that i think some of
the opec plus states are concerned that
you know if they add more production for
a month or two it's not really going to
make a big difference
um but i do think that the political
pressure on opec plus is going to
intensify
this is a serious supply shock
and opec stated role is to manage
volatility in the market and prevent
volatility you know it feels like the
market doesn't have anyone at the wheel
right now
and it feels like saudi arabia the ua
and others are ignoring the demands of
big consumers not just the united states
but countries like china and india as
well
so i think in the coming days you know
lots of things are possible it's
possible you'll have
you know a revision of the opec plus
terms in next month's meeting you could
see a unilateral move by saudi arabia
but clearly they want to get some
concessions from washington before they
do those things okay let's bring in
later then in uh moscow good to have you
with us uh ladies
what does a u.s and uk ban on on russian
oil
really mean for russia its economy its
president will it hurt either
no for russia it's not a problem and if
united states and uk or for example
european union will stop to buy russian
oil
because it's not
so big part of russian economy and we
have already deal with china to provide
more oil to this country for next year
we have a new contract segment this year
and i think it's uh more problematic for
united states and the uk
and
because
there was first shooting our lag by
united states when they imposed
sanctions against iran and venezuela and
now we see that technical
opportunity in venezuela is broken by
american sanctions and they just cannot
provide more oil
to united states for example if there is
a political decision and
of course there is also option about
natural gas and it's more dangerous for
europe or european economy than for
russia and for example now uh price for
digital inside of russia is more cheaper
than before because of sanctions and
it's good for development of domestic
economics of russia
so for the moment i see
no
serious problem for russia itself
because of this oil sanctions okay what
if the eu were to follow the us and the
uk's lead and ban imports of russian oil
and and russian gas i can see already
that cornelius shaking her head i'll
come back to you in a moment but but
would that
is it would would that worry moscow
uh i assure that european countries most
of uh european union
can not to find alternatives of russian
gas and oil because half of european
union country strongly depends of
russian supplies it's
not only north stream one but
it's uh elsa oil production and it's
some kind of logistic it will be a chain
reaction and will deeply impact on
european economic
[Music]
itself
so i think they will try to find
alternative in a few years but at the
same time russia will find alternative
for new market in asian parts of the
world for some china india and pakistan
and more
countries who
have energy hunter
and will look for russian gas and oil
and maybe it will be more cheaper
because of this situation but for now we
see that uh prices for gas and oil
growing up and it's uh seriously
impacted on uh
european and uh united states
citizens because
your
community i see i
mean community of united states of
european country are
economic eccentric or communities not
like in russia it's a very serious
mistake to see russia the same
like of united states and for some
german your friends we have another type
of community so it's a very big
difference and it will be
more a problem for the west itself okay
cornelia tell me why then why
won't the u.s the eu rather follow the
usa uk
it's too it's two things here you need
to decide do you need to divide between
oil and gas if you have oil it will
always find the market and you fi you
saw that at the beginning of last week
when russian cargoes had a hard time
finding a market the chinese and the
indians just waited until the discount
was low enough and they bought it so
that will go gas is more difficult
because it requires infrastructure and
our russian colleague was absolutely
right it's not a light switch you know
if we want to get let's say more lng in
most lngs on 25-year contracts and
especially the middle eastern and the
asian cargos are promised on these the
molecules are promised to china japan
and korea if you talk to some of the
analysts they say 10 could get diverted
to the to europe
the us similarly they will have about 12
million tons of new cap of new lng
coming on the market in about five years
time
i think we need to heat houses in europe
before the five years time plus you need
the infrastructure you need the
regasification terminals we don't have
enough of them and the infrastructure
linking them into the pipeline system so
again it's not a light switch it really
it really takes time and again oil is
easier but it's also not that easy
because don't forget that refiners are
tuned to certain grades so if they
really are made an old refinery that's
very dependent on the euros grade will
have a hard time just substituting it so
it looks easy and i'm sure to the
politician it is easy but to the guy in
the industry it's hellishly complex ben
what are the political risks of banning
russian oil and gas for western leaders
does it threaten to split the west's
currently
fairly united response to russia's
actions in ukraine
i mean the economic risks are huge if
you impose a full
full sanctions on russian energy exports
that's a recipe for recession
um
it just is not possible for the oil
market to accommodate a loss of that
kind of magnitude and this is the reason
why we haven't seen direct sanctions yet
and even with
you know sanctions on just the russian
central bank russian financial
institutions uh other russian entities
we've already seen a big supply loss no
one knows exactly how much is offline
now but it's a good bet that around 2.53
million barrels a day of crude products
are already offline today even without
direct sanctions
um if you rent that up to eight million
barrels a day you know all russian
exports
there's simply no way for the market to
cope with the loss on that scale
and so the prices would shoot up it
would be a severe dent economic activity
you know the market would panic um
that's a recipe for demand destruction
it would be unmanageable i think um so i
think
there are clearly a huge downside risk
to doing it
president putin has called
sanctions he's referred to sanctions as
an act of war um to what extent do you
think he would be prepared to perhaps
preempt
further western bans and just simply cut
off supply anyway i think that russia is
ready for trade and future with the
united states with european union and mr
putin before told many times that we are
ready for cooperation and
need to
make difference between a different type
of economics politics etc
so in ultimate
reason i think that russia yes came to
impose counter sanctions against united
states and european union and to cut
gas on all the supplies
to those countries if there will be
some very serious impact on the russian
economy in future but now in nearly a
few months
i see no any danger for russian
economics
from the energy sector
cornelia we're talking about the
economic damage that a sustained uh high
oil price could do there's the old
saying that the best cure for a high
price is a high price if demand fell as
consumers just decide that it's too
expensive um then so would the price but
at what economic cost
well at a huge economic cost and you
know obviously we'll see some demand
destruction but our economies are still
fueled by oil and gas and by the way
coal you know if if the germans let's
say go off gas they will need some coal
you need some base loaders to keep the
lights on so that's a huge cost and you
know the cost goes beyond those
countries you saw the german
economy minister and deputy chancellor
say if we get off russian gas
immediately he fears for cohesion in the
country and the man all about habek is
agreeing he is no fan of fossil fuels
um and what's what goes beyond that if
we see hyperinflation that's not good
for the economy global economy and also
don't forget food because
um ukraine and and russia
make up about 30 percent of sort of the
global food supply the ukraine is 50 of
the world food program fuels the
food supply so you know the the the
developing countries the sudans the
somalias of this world will really feel
that because they won't they won't get
the grain and they won't even if they
get it they won't be able to avoid it
plus the fertilizers gas is the direct
input to fertilizers let's take germany
as an example out of three major
suppliers of fertilizer to a russian so
we're really really very interconnected
ben i was i was reading today
that the biggest strategic gas storage
reservoir in western europe is in
germany
and that that strategic reservoir is
owned by a specific subsidiary of
gazprom
germany in particular of course worried
about its energy security
uh while prices may rise uncomfortably
for u.s consumers i mean there's little
chance of the lights going out in the us
i i don't think the same
could be said for for many western
european
states to what extent does germany have
only itself to blame due to deregulation
of its energy sector allowing russian
companies to hold or own significant
stakes in in german energy companies and
germany's not alone in that is it yeah
there have been some pretty important
changes in the european gas market in
recent years i mean they basically moved
away from
you know long-term oil wind contracts
towards more gas on gas competition
um more reliance on you know the spot
market short term um and that worked
pretty well for a while
and you know the market is essentially
broken in the last six months and we've
had these enormous run-ups and gas and
electricity prices in europe
you know the dependence on russia is
really hard to break
but there are some european policies
that i think have exacerbated this
situation one of the things that the
international energy agency and the
europeans have noted is that they really
need to have an all-out effort from now
until next winter to build up gas
storage as much as possible to fill all
those tanks
um and it's going to be extremely
expensive for them to do that and gas
supplies are scarce i mean basically lng
producers around the world are producing
full tilt
and as i think corneli mentioned earlier
you know not every country in europe has
an lng import terminal
those that do have regas terminals
regasification terminals they're not
connected to all those markets so all of
them are going to have to try to refill
gas as much as possible
you know they can't completely get
around their dependence on russia to do
that they're still going to be dependent
on gas from but they'll do everything
they can to build interconnections to
increase gas storage and i think they're
really going to have to look at gas
policies and try to figure out why this
market in europe has gone so haywire and
what they can do to build more
resilience in the sixth year leonard
you think that president putin is
prepared to sit this out while
uh the west potentially uh shoots itself
in the in the foot economically and and
causes a a
huge economic damage to itself
i think that russia is preparing for
different type of sanctions uh also our
prime minister uh mr mischus already
thought that we have calculated risks
about
different type of sanctions from the
west
so i think
more sanctions will be
more dangerous for european union and
the united states because russia will
impose more essentials exceptions
we
should talk about not only oil gas
sector and also about uh food
fertilizers like caliph told recently
and about for example that higher space
of russia is closed for companies from
european union and there is
also
different types of
sanctions
that russia introduced against
european assets inside russia about
capitals etc
so yes it's kind of uh
war at work by other means
and
geoeconomically
i think
it will be more serious damage for some
european countries that for us
okay there i'm afraid we're going to
have to leave it uh many thanks indeed
to you all for uh discussing that with
us here today ben cahill
in
washington cornelia maya
in bern and in moscow leonard seven
as always thank you for watching don't
forget you can see the program again at
any time just by going to the website at
aljazeera.com
for further discussion around this topic
join us on our facebook page you'll find
that at facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story and you can join the
conversation on twitter i handle at aj
inside story from me adrian finnegan and
the whole team here in doha thanks for
watching we'll see you again
[Music]